It's funny, because I'll
tell people I work at Google.
And they'll go,
what do you work on?
I design Search.
And they kind of pause for
a second, and they're like,
what is there to design?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Design is a balance
between a number
of things-- the utility, the
usability, and the beauty.
I think that you kind of
require those three ingredients.
One of the first
things that I did
when I joined the
Search team was
that I said that
Search was too slow.
The response was,
well, we probably
have to change
the speed of light
in order to solve
this problem, OK?
And I said, no, I think
it could be faster.
The box in which you type,
it was the default size
that input boxes
are in the browser.
And so for like a decade,
that's what it was.
This is the way in which
people are talking to Google.
They're doing it through
this tiny little box.
I said, well, why don't
we make that bigger?
It was a very simple
design change.
We just made the
input box larger.
Commensurately, the
font size got larger.
And the autocompletions
gets larger.
And people started
noticing them more.
By noticing them more, they
actually started using it more.
They were actually able to
get to the answer they wanted
faster, just by tweaking
the size of this box.
There's lots of things that look
very small that you might not
notice that we changed to
make the experience better.
Over time, it actually
really adds up.
I still think it's too slow.
That's why we're investing
so heavily in the voice
experience, because it's
actually much easier to ask
more complicated questions than
if you had to type them in,
particularly if you have
to type them in on a phone.
As you speak, the
words are appearing,
and it feels so fluid and fast.
Once you start removing these
speed bumps, even if they're
tiny speed bumps and just
getting them out of the way,
that's pretty transformative.
Arthur C. Clarke
has a famous quote.
"Any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable
from magic."
To make magic is to actually
make the technology go away.
That's what I see my job
is, is to craft experiences
that just work.
[MUSIC PLAYING]